White House chief of staff John Kelly
says president Trump's view on
immigration has evolved in a meeting
with the Hispanic Caucus on Capitol Hill
Kelley reportedly said there will be no
wall quote that Mexico will pay for
lawmakers say Kelley told them certain
things are said during the campaign that
are uninformed Kelly's comments were
first reported by Washington Post
congressional reporter ed O'Keefe he's
also a CBS News contributor and is with
us from Washington good morning ed good
morning guys great reporting yesterday
interesting to hear what the White House
chief of staff told members of Congress
that he was uninformed and then later in
a Fox News interview saying that the
president's views on the wall are
evolving you've seen the president's
tweets this morning trying to recorrect
that record end of day what does it mean
it means nobody knows what exactly the
president wants to do here and that's a
problem
absent specific guidelines from the
president Republicans aren't quite sure
how to proceed because they could put
something up and cast votes on it and
had the president end up vetoing it and
putting them in a really difficult
position so until the president gets
specific on what exactly he'd like to
see paired with permanent legal
protections for dreamers Republicans
aren't quite sure what they should be
doing so can you clarify for that for
everybody cuz you saw Nancy Cordes ask
the Senate Majority Leader yesterday
about this and he said until we know
what the president does we're not gonna
set up here spinning our wheels what
exactly is the debating point around the
question of daca nobody disputes that
the the dreamers should be protected and
that Congress is ultimately probably
going to pass something the issue is of
course remember Republicans control
Congress and they don't want to just do
that they want to pair it with something
they want to make changes in border
security they want to make changes in
what's called family based migration and
the issue is well to what extent are you
going to go do you want to fully fund
new wall and fence construction on the
Mexico border or are you willing to put
up just some of that money now and
continue that debate in the coming years
and the president continues to say as he
did in this tweet this morning we got to
do that wall it's got it's gonna be
see-through in some parts which is Trump
for a fence and then just the question
is exactly how much money do you put up
that he would find
acceptable and that is what has been
infuriating Democrats and Republicans is
he won't just keep to one idea and this
is in an acute moment because this is
tied to keeping the government open so
where are Democrats on this specifically
in the Senate in terms of are they going
to vote for a spending deal that does
not include daca and if they don't does
that mean the government shutting down
so remember you need 60 votes to pass a
spending bill in the Senate fifty-one
Republicans right now but two of them at
least have voted no in the past on these
things
one more Lindsey Graham says he's not
force you down to 47 which means you're
gonna need at least 13 Democrats to vote
with the Republicans 18 of them voted
YES on the last short-term spending bill
in December but at least three of them
yesterday said they're voting no so that
leaves just 15 today we may hear from
more Democrats who have voted yes in the
past saying I don't like this I'm not
voting for it if they can't get 60 votes
we're headed to a shutdown all right ed
O'Keefe thanks for breaking it down